Casi ningún estudiante de anatomía podría hacerlo sin ayuda de elementos visuales.
Porque al final,
recuerde uno cada pequeña estructura o no,
las ilustraciones médicas hacen que estudiar anatomía sea muy intrigante.
Al mirarlas,
en realidad estamos viendo un manual de nosotros mismos.
Pero ¿qué sucede cuando hemos terminado de estudiar?
Estas bellas ilustraciones quedan
en las páginas de un libro médico,
o en una aplicación,
y son referenciadas solo de ser necesario.
Y para el público,
las ilustraciones médicas pueden encontrarse de forma pasiva
en las paredes de la oficina de un médico.
Desde los inicios de la medicina moderna,
la ilustración médica,
y, por lo tanto, la anatomía,
han existido sobre todo dentro del ámbito de la educación médica.
Sin embargo, hoy ocurre algo fascinante.
Los artistas sacan la anatomía de los confines del mundo médico
y la están empujando al espacio público.
Durante los últimos nueve años, he cataloga y compartido
este aumento en el arte anatómico con el público...
todo desde mi punto de vista de ilustradora médica.
Pero antes de mostrarles cómo los artistas rescatan hoy la anatomía,
es importante entender cómo el arte influenció a la anatomía en el pasado.
La anatomía es por propia naturaleza una ciencia visual;
y los primeros anatomistas en entender esto vivieron durante el Renacimiento.
Se basaron en los artistas
para ayudar a anunciar sus descubrimientos a sus compañeros en el público.
Y esto no solo para enseñar sino también para entretener,
resultó en unas de las ilustraciones anatómicas más extrañas.
La anatomía quedó atrapada en una lucha entre la ciencia, el arte y la cultura
que se prolongó durante más de 500 años.
Los artistas ilustraron cadáveres disecados como vivos,
que hicieron stripteases anatómicos humorísticos.
Imaginen ver eso en los textos hoy.
También los mostraron en su mayoría muertos...
sin quererlo despojados de su piel.
Las extremidades posaban a menudo literalmente como naturaleza muerta.
Algunas ilustraciones incluso incluyen referencias a la cultura pop.
Esta es Clara,
un famoso rinoceronte que viajaba por Europa a mediados de 1700;
en esa época ver un rinoceronte era una rareza emocionante.
Incluirla en esta ilustración era similar al patrocinio de celebridades de hoy.
La introducción del color
le dio una nueva profundidad y claridad a la anatomía
que la hizo imponente.
A principios del siglo XX,
el equilibrio perfecto de ciencia y arte finalmente se dio
con la aparición de ilustradores médicos.
Crearon una representación universal de la anatomía,
algo que no estaba ni vivo ni muerto,
libre de las influencias de la cultura artística.
Y ese foco en la precisión sin lujos
fue precisamente en beneficio de la educación médica.
Y esto es con lo que estudiamos hoy.
Pero ¿por qué la ilustración médica
-- del pasado y el presente --
capta nuestra imaginación?
Ahora, estamos en sintonía innatamente con la belleza del cuerpo humano.
Y la ilustración médica sigue siendo arte.
Nada puede provocar una respuesta emocional
-- de la alegría al total disgusto --
más que el cuerpo humano.
Y hoy,
los artistas provistos de esa emoción,
toman la anatomía del mundo de la medicina,
y le dan un nuevo impulso a través del arte en las formas más imaginativas.
Un ejemplo perfecto de esto es el artista español contemporáneo Fernando Vicente.
Toma ilustraciones anatómicas decimonónicas del cuerpo masculino
y las envuelve en una sensualidad femenina.
Las mujeres de sus pinturas nos instan a ver más allá de su anatomía superficial,
presentando de este modo una fuerte femineidad,
ausente antes en la historia de la representación anatómica.
El arte también se ve en la reparación y la recuperación del cuerpo humano.
Esta es la radiografía de una mujer que se fracturó y se dislocó el tobillo
en un accidente de patinaje.
Como homenaje a su trauma,
encargó al arquitecto Federico Carbajal con sede en Montreal
una escultura de alambre de su pierna dañada.
Vean los tornillos rojo brillante aumentados en la escultura.
Son los tornillos quirúrgicos reales usados en la reconstrucción de su tobillo.
Es hardware médico resignificado como arte.
La gente a menudo me pregunta cómo elijo el arte que muestro en línea
o en presentaciones en galerías.
Y para mí es un equilibrio entre la técnica y un concepto
que extiende los límites de la anatomía como una forma de autoconocimiento,
razón por la que me impactó la obra de Michael Reedy.
Sus dibujos serios a menudo se superponen a elementos de humor.
Por ejemplo, miren su rostro.
Observen esas marcas rojas.
Michael manifiesta la inseguridad de una enfermedad cutánea
como dibujos de monstruos maníacos
molestos y fuera de control en el fondo.
En la figura duplicada,
muestra la anatomía completa
y la cubre de brillo,
y le da aspecto de dulce.
Al hacer esto,
Michael resta importancia a la percepción común de la anatomía
tan estrechamente ligada a la enfermedad y la muerte.
Ahora bien, el siguiente concepto quizá no tiene mucho sentido,
pero la anatomía humana ya no se limita a los humanos.
De pequeños,
¿alguna vez desearon que sus juguetes pudieran cobrar vida?
Jason Freeny hizo cumplir esos sueños
con sus disecciones mágicas de juguetes.
(Risas)
Podría pensarse que esto traería un borde mórbido
a los personajes de la infancia inocentes de uno,
pero Jason dice de sus disecciones:
"Algo que nunca he visto en la reacción de un niño a mi trabajo es miedo".
Siempre maravilla,
asombro,
y ganas de explorar.
El miedo a la anatomía y las tripas es una reacción aprendida.
Esta anatomización también se extiende a objetos con carga política y social.
En "Anatomía de la guerra" de Noah Scalin,
vemos un arma diseccionada para revelar los órganos humanos.
Pero si miran de cerca,
observarán que carece de cerebro.
Y si siguen mirando, también podrían notar
que Noah ha ubicado el recto con sumo cuidado
en la punta de la pistola.
Ahora, este es un nuevo artista que sigo desde hace muchos años,
que veo que entusiasma al público con la anatomía.
Danny Quirk es un joven artista
que pinta sus temas en el proceso de autodisección.
Tuerce las reglas de la ilustración médica
mediante luces y sombras muy dramáticas.
Y esto crea una ilusión 3D
que se presta muy bien a la pintura directa sobre la piel humana.
Danny hace que parezca que se ha eliminado la piel.
Y este efecto
-- cool y de tatuaje --
fácilmente se transforma en una ilustración médica.
Danny está actualmente viajando por el mundo,
enseñando anatomía al público a través de sus pinturas corporales,
por eso fue tan impactante descubrir
que le rechazaron en los programas de ilustración médica.
Pero le va bien.
Luego están los artistas
que extraen anatomía tanto del mundo de la medicina como del mundo del arte
y la colocan directamente en las calles.
Las SHOK-1 en Londres son radiografías gigantes de iconos de la cultura pop.
Sus rayos X muestran cómo la cultura puede llegar a tener una anatomía propia,
y, al contrario, cómo la cultura puede ser parte de la anatomía de una persona.
Se llega a admirar su obra
porque reproducir radiografías a mano, y mucho menos con pintura en aerosol,
es extremadamente difícil.
Pero, de nuevo se trata de un artista urbano,
que también tiene un título en química aplicada.
Nychos, un artista urbano austríaco,
lleva el término "vista explotada" a un nivel completamente nuevo,
salpicando disecciones humanas y animales en las paredes de todo el mundo.
Bajo la influencia del cómic y el heavy metal,
Nychos inserta una energía muy juvenil y tentadora a la anatomía,
que me encanta.
Los artistas callejeros creen que el arte pertenece al público.
Y esta anatomía urbana es muy cautivante
porque es la que más se aparta del mundo médico.
Obliga a mirarla,
y a confrontar las propias percepciones de la anatomía,
por encontrarla hermosa,
grotesca,
mórbida
o inspiradora, como yo.
Que acaso provoque estas respuestas
se debe a la relación íntima y a menudo cambiante con ella.
Todos los artistas que he mostrado aquí hoy
refieren ilustraciones médicas para su arte.
Pero para ellos,
la anatomía no es solo algo a memorizar,
sino un punto de partida para entender el cuerpo en un nivel significativo;
para representarlo de manera que podamos identificarnos,
ya sea mediante dibujos animados,
pintura corporal
o arte urbano.
El arte anatómico tiene el poder
para llegar más allá de las páginas de un libro de texto médico,
para encender una emoción en el público,
y revigorizar un entusiasmo en el mundo médico,
en definitiva, conectar el fuero interno con el cuerpo a través del arte.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)